when you were 90 you rarely talk about
what you did you always talk about what
you didn't do if you were lucky enough
and if you wanted to get inspired to
spend just a little time sick
75 to 90 year old that you don't know
and you listen and you talk but she or
he will talk about is what they didn't
do I should have married Ricky Thompson
I wish and this is a big one I wish I
did something different in my career the
thing that impacted me as a workaholic
and someone who's really ambitious I
wish to spend more time with my kids
that hit me hard you were not born for a
long time and you're gonna be dead
forever the moments we have here are
small I ask all of you whether in the
first quarter or entering the fourth
quarter or anywhere in between it's
never too late to get better it's never
too late to fight for more happiness
ever